so Marvel's G and done something that
well both the big two tend to do they've
done a little bit of a reccom but this
one is special to me this has to do with
the origins specifically the birth of
one Nightcrawler very popular X-Men
character for a while now since about
2003 I believe Nightcrawler's parentage
has been Shape Shifter Mystique it's his
mother a zazil a literal demon is his
father it's now been changed to Mystique
is his father and her longtime lover
Destiny is his mother the specifics are
weird naturally it has TRS of racing
people's memories and if you think or
have heard anyone say that this is you
know wokeness and they're changing the
characters yeah they are changing it but
they're Chang into what it was supposed
to be in the first place Chris Claremont
who created Mystique wanted to do this
back in the80s and it was vetoed this is
a restoring of the original artistic
intent and I am so happy to see it